how are you feeling in terms of what
you're seeing people talking about you
know publicly versus uh kind of how you
once you synthesize all this different
data we're about to talk about how do
you feel well i personally try to remove
the emotion from it but i do feel like
on twitter or whatever you've seen a lot
of uh you know just general fear or like
anxiety and panic um in the market and
uh you know i think
this kind of near-term price action is
has
been provoking that for sure uh but you
know i'm trying to just look at this
from an objective standpoint and you
know just read whatever the data is
telling me so i don't really have any
kind of like emotional
reaction to you know what's going on i
try to just like
ignore that
got it all right so when we get started
here the first thing that uh we've got
is obviously the price uh and a lot of
that is being affected by the perp
futures dominance all the perp uh kind
of uh interest in the market etc
before we jump into the actual data
explain exactly what's going on with
these kind of futures and how that
relates to price in general what can
happen in the futures market that makes
price go up or go down as we as we look
at this data sure so anyone who follows
me on twitter has probably seen me
posting consistently for the last like
two or three weeks about open interest
um and the build up of open interest and
so what open interest is is open
interest is just telling you the amount
of contracts that are open for
for perpetual swaps
um and so the way to think of this is
these perp contracts are just
essentially bets on bitcoin's price
there's a long side and a short side
and so open interest is just telling you
how many of those contracts are open
and so it's it's kind of a way to gauge
essentially how much pressure is
building up in the perp market but it
doesn't tell you the positioning of
those
of those contracts or the you know the
market participants on both sides of the
bet so i oftentimes get asked like when
i'll post open interest can you post
the long open interest or can you post
the short open interest
and the answer is no and that's because
there's a long and short on both sides
of every single contract so at all times
the amount of longs and shorts is always
50 50 in the pert market there's never
more longs than shorts or more shorts
than longs what you're trying to do is
you're trying to understand what is the
risk that's held by both participants on
both sides of the contract so for
example
you could have like a retail d gen
that's long on one side of the contract
meanwhile on the other side of the
contract on the short side it's a market
maker and so market makers are generally
delta neutral which just a fancy term
for saying that they have no directional
bias
right so they they essentially get paid
a fee for for providing liquidity to
different exchanges and so their their
job is to essentially just provide
liquidity and
allow people to get fills for their
orders and then they get paid a fee from
the exchange for the amount of volume
that their liquidity that they're
providing to that specific exchange
um and so you know
in that example i just used right you
have the retail guy on one side and he's
just looking to you know access cheap
leverage on the other end you have a you
know market maker who has no you know
uh
directional bias because they're hedged
and that's that's where the you know
delta neutral part comes in they can
hedge either if in this case i'm saying
they're short right
you know they could hedge by going along
in the spot market and then they have no
directional bias um and so you know
that that
you know the risk profile of both
participants there is completely
different right the person taking the
risk is the retail person on the wrong
side in the example i just described
and so we can get into in a second some
of the things that
you can look at to try to gauge the
aggression and the risk that's held by
the different market participants that
are making up the open interest
but open interest is solely telling you
and by the way you can also look at the
context of the open where you know where
open interest is being opened how it's
interacting with price to also kind of
get a gauge of that
but open interest in itself just saying
that there's high open interest doesn't
mean that it's necessarily bullish or
bearish in itself it's just saying that
you know you're building up the pressure
or in
in my mind that means that you can
expect volatility right because you have
a large amount of leverage that's built
up in the system
okay so when we look at this you had a
tweet on what is this the fourth of
january and you basically were saying if
there's anything i feel confident about
in the intermediate term it's that
volatility is coming to bitcoin and you
then later followed it up with a second
tweet that uh or i'm sorry there's a
tweet before that where you basically i
don't know which direction it's going to
go so i think you were very much like
hey volatility is coming we're just kind
of uh trading sideways here and that
volatility could go up or down i don't
yet have an opinion on that all i know
is that that volatility is coming so
talk us through a little bit as to like
why were you so convinced that the
volatility was coming which ultimately
was a kind of a downward move in the
price but what was telling you that that
volatility was coming
yeah so first of all like some people
are probably gonna look like you know
listen to this who are a bit you know
less sophisticated and say well you're
just saying you know price could go up
or down like what good use is that you
know first of all like i think you you
know if you don't have an opinion you
don't always need to have an opinion and
so in this case
um i didn't think that some of the clues
from the positioning of the uh
of the of the perps was that clear to me
as to where you know this was going to
kind of resolve
um we could talk about what i think at
this current state but at the you know
the time that i put this out um and the
reasoning is because like for example
like the funding setup is just
completely different from for example
summer where you know we were talking
about a massive short squeeze because
funding was you know in a prolonged
regime of negative funding and was going
further negative as price was grinding
above the lows at the time you know the
positioning was pretty clear to me that
okay this was short um you know lately
just because we have just muted funding
i don't think it's been quite as clear
and so with that being said
it is useful when you you know when
you're expecting volatility but perhaps
don't have some kind of directional bias
because you can still
um you know make a play on that either
through options or something called move
contracts
on ftx which are essentially bets on
volatility that's why they're called
move contracts
um and so the reason i was just
expecting this was
a we had you know this massive build up
of open interest that hadn't gotten
wiped out at all
especially when you compare open
interest to market cap so this is really
important
this is the in the this section of these
four tweets the one in the bottom right
this is looking at the amount of open
interest in the pert market relative to
market cap and why that's important is
because
you need to get a gauge of how much
weight that open interest has relative
to bitcoin's market cap right because
you could have you know x amount of open
interest but if if market cap is five
times larger than what it is now then it
has a smaller overall impact on the on
the market um you know versus if
you know if the market cap was half the
size it was and we still had the same
amount of open interest then open
interest would have double the you know
effect on the market so
that ratio is a good gauge of you know
how impactful or how influenced the
market is going to be by these uh by the
derivatives
and so in combination with that the
other three charts that i have
are looking at implied volatility and so
this is the volatility that's getting
priced into options um and so the market
was pricing in really low volatility uh
we were at the lowest implied volatility
since um the end of uh summer so it was
just showing you like people were
expecting you know really low volatility
generally consolidation leads to
expansion expansion leads to volatility
um
and so like
i'm sorry expansion leads to
consolidation but um you know we've been
in this kind of period of consolidation
really tight range between 45 to 52.
meanwhile we've had this massive build
up of leverage and the options market
hasn't been pricing in that volatility
so
i was i was looking to take a bet on
volatility i you know like full
transparency i didn't execute on this um
so that's you know like what what good
is analysis if executed poorly right um
so that's kind of a lesson learned from
this for me in terms of i didn't
actually execute on that but um yeah
those are some of the things that i was
looking at and you know perhaps things
that you can apply moving forward um
between the the the dynamics in the
derivatives market as to when you can
potentially expect volatility